a swamp creature that burns evildoers
and also guards the point where all
realities meet yes marvel's man thing is
far more than just another grotesque
creature one of the highlights of
disney's t23 expo 2022 was a trailer for
werewolf by night the long anticipated
special scheduled to hit disney plus on
october 7th just in time for the spooky
halloween season a special will serve as
a homecoming and live-action debut for
several marvel horror characters chief
among them the titular werewolf jack
russell and monster hunter elsa
bloodstone i can't wait to find out what
breed of evil you are if you're not a
fan of the marvel comics horror titles
that started in the 1970s he might have
been a little perplexed by one
terrifying monster that makes a very
quick appearance in the trailer flashing
his giant claws and his tentacled head
he looks like something out of the works
of hp lovecraft and his backstory is no
less weird the creature is a shambling
conscience-less heap that appears to be
anything but human but don't write this
off as just a jump scare this is no
random monster cooked up by one of
disney's visual effects artists it is
none other than the menacing man thing
one of the most iconic characters in the
marvel universe and an ominous figure
whose arrival to the mcu has some fans
howling with excitement and if you're at
all familiar with manthing's role in the
comics you already know that he could
have a much more significant place in
the future of the mcu that might be
immediately apparent the shambling
remorseless creature known as the man
thing may seem like a typical monster of
the week or a rip off of dc comic's
swamp thing but in reality he's a big
deal and his first appearance predates
swamp things by two months manthing
actually carried his own solo comic for
years in the 1970s writer steve gerber
put his own unique spin on the character
and turned him into a cult classic the
origin of the man thing is simple a
scientist by the name of ted salas
working on a secret chemical experiment
in the florida everglades is pursued by
bad guys seeking to steal the formula
the chase ends with salis crashing his
car into a swamp where mysterious forces
combined with the chemicals they've been
working on to permanently transform
salis into the bizarre entity known as
the man thing manthing is a slow moving
creature with a penchant for thwarting
various criminal schemes
despite the fact that he has very little
if any conscious mind left to speak of
gerber created the character's classic
tagline whoever knows fear burns at the
touch of the man thing the phrase
describes another of manthing's
abilities to sense and feed off of fear
and other emotions and nearby people
good people don't tend to fear man thing
as they senseate decency within him but
wrongdoers react with terror when they
do so his touch quite literally burns
their flesh manthing also plays a
shockingly prominent role in marvel's
multiverse because it turns out that the
everglades are the nexus of all
realities manthane is a guardian of that
nexus it's a no-brainer then that the
man thing would be part of the werewolf
by nightcast of characters the character
can prove to be highly significant to
the recently announced multiverse saga
of the marvel cinematic universe given
his role as guardian of the nexus with
mcu characters including spider-man and
doctor strange having already gotten
involved with various multiversal
entanglements the table for secret wars
is well on its way to being set the
multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
real
and
dangerous furthermore some familiar
looking uniforms spotted in the werewolf
by night trailer indicate what might be
the time variance authority from loki
possibly hinting that manthing's extra
dimensional role may carry over to his
mcu incarnation with all this multiverse
stuff happening it just makes sense that
man thing would take up that mantle in
the mcu as well that's all speculation
though fans will have to wait until
october 7th when werewolf by night hits
disney plus to find out exactly how
manthing fits into the mcu